ces hommes et femmes de droite et de
centre-droit ont préféré lire monsieur
coquerel président de la commission eric
coquerel ancien membre de la ligue
communiste révolutionnaire
eric coquerel adversaires de nos
institutions de notre modèle de notre
histoire eric coquerel qui a théorisé
pour jean luc mélenchon le rapprochement
avec l'électorat musulman de france au
poids ou l'étiquette d' islamo-gauchiste
lui colle désormais à la peau le les
dernières présidentielles ce
on avait l'impression qu'un français sur
deux était raciste parce qu'ils ont voté
le pen ou mais moi je suis convaincu que
la france n'est pas raciste je suis sûr
que ces sept c'est un vote de misère ccc
c'était plus une plainte contre macron
et et dire combien c'est anormal cette
répartition
cette mauvaise répartition des richesses
donc je ne veux pas croire que la france
soit raciste ça me semblait impossible
de penser ça c'est cet homme qu ont
préféré élire les députés de renaissance
les députés des républicains plutôt qu
imaginer une alliance de circonstance
avec les députés du rassemblement
national la duplicité la couarde is
l'irresponsabilité et le cynisme aussi
de ses députés qui trahissent sans doute
leurs propres électeurs restera comme un
marqueur est un révélateur de ce début
de mandature
à l'opposé des mains ciel
[Musique]
mais on est où là
m
ça
tu veux
il y aura compris que vous préférez eric
coquerel à quelqu'un du rassemblement
lozère a dit ça mais ce n'est ni
l'origine ni l'autre à bah oui avoue
vieira n'est pas isolé et bien demandé
aux paysans pense va écouter les
électeurs ont voté au lieu de demander
aux électeurs ce qu'ils ont pas
aujourd'hui on a nos résultats demandez
à vos électeurs ce qu'ils en pensent
dans un choix comme ça s'il préfère n'y
aura pas d'année en effet il n'y aura
jamais d'alliance entre l air il
rassemble nationale c'est clair si la
longueur entre les sièges et dans la
moyenne avec ses 82 cm la largeur elle a
été réduite de 45 à moins de 43 cm une
façon d'optimiser le remplissage
alors que dans 1 à 350 d'air france
chaque rangée compte neuf sièges
frenchie lui en a casé 10 grâce à cette
stratégie la compagnie peut vendre 87
sièges de plus qu'air france pour le
même avion je voulais savoir déjà est ce
que tu sais compter puisque dise
clairement quand je vois qu'on quatre
jours ma famille a réussi à faire des
miracles pour 250 personnes et que tu
m'as 8la le manque de respect je crois
que la même dépassé la tour eiffel c'est
pas possible le respect est liée sur le
principe que je donnais 8 parce que
c'est ta famille qui a fait le repas par
respect pour ma famille 8 oui tu as un
culot et un toupet incroyable au fait tu
vois ça c'est quelque chose qui me reste
là mais la palme de la surtaxe est la
plus chère c'est la faute de frappe
en faisant sa réservation ce passager a
fait une petite erreur il a mis deux
fois son prénom
questionna sommes un jour mon affaire
sur une personne ça
c'est olivier
sans consentement changement c'est une
menace anticapitaliste antilibéral anti
argent alors c'est vrai que l'argent n'a
pas bonne presse en france mais il en
faut bien les entreprises en gagne
c'est une menace pour tout ce que nous
sommes alors quand vous interrogez
débattront
évidemment entre deux mots entre
guillemets telles que vous les
définissez puisqu'il s'agit de mots de
deux extrémismes il faut choisir le
moindre pour nos entreprises
[Musique]
tu paies fait le père de famille doit
débourser 160 euros auxquels s'ajoutent
2 175 euros parce qu'il n'a pas
enregistré les cinq passagers
en fait j'en prenais ma rage parce que
j'ai perdu ma clé
que ce soit clair monsieur j'ai perdu ma
clé on m'a chanté pour m'aider à
démarrer on m'a chanté leurs auteurs
l'art comme ça gmac à l'entité je suis
désolé j'ai travaillé je suis crêpier je
travaille dur et vous énervez pas comme
ça merde moi je m'énerve pas avec vous
ne vous restez calme tant que je me pose
des questions c'est tout quoi saadi
faudra juste faire attention aux poutres
ans
[Musique]
s'est cognée
ça c'est compliqué ça lui coûterait pas
rentrer trop tard le soir trop fatigué
j'ai mon assurance j'ai tous les papiers
et tout
est à nous et pas tout monsieur parce
que la carte grise à des parents règlent
entre aussi tous pareils est pareil ben
non cieux les points votre nom mais
parce qu'il faut un somme mais j'ai pas
eu le temps bah oui mais bon
c'est crêpier au
travail douze heures par jour
c'est pas
si la maison de ludmilla est en ruine
je vous montre mon jardin elle est
revenue cultiver son jardin
je trouve incroyable que vous cultivez
votre jardin et vous avez très jolie
fille j'aime beaucoup mon jardin c'est
joli rose les roses de l'espoir oui
c'est les roses de l'espoir